monsieur le ministre merci donc d'avoir
accepté le principe de cette audition et
de l'avoir maintenu alors même que vous
êtes contraint de le faire à distance
nous sommes évidemment contre un ou tous
d'apprendre à vivre et à travailler
pendant l'épidémie
tout en respectant évidemment les règles
sanitaires
alors nous nous étions vus le 3 novembre
dernier et déjà depuis cette date qui
n'est pas si lointaine on peut dire que
le paysage international a déjà
considérablement évolué du fait
notamment de l'entrée en fonction du
président byden et des premiers pas de
la nouvelle administration américaine
citons en vrac que la réintégration des
états unis dans l'accord de paris sur le
climat la volonté de reprendre les
négociations avec l'iran sur le gie
cypihot et à condition bien sûr que les
i les iraniens respectent leurs
obligations dont malgré tout il semble
persister dangereusement à vouloir
s'écarter
le 19 février dernier lors de la
conférence de munich sur la sécurité le
président biden déclarait l'amérique est
de retour l'alliance transatlantique et
de retour alors vous nous direz s'il y a
un vrai changement si vous ressentez ce
vrai changement de doctrine de la
politique étrangère américaine
ou bien s'il faut au contraire noté des
premières constante avec
l'administration précédente focalisation
sur la chine ou autre par exemple en ce
qui concerne le moyen-orient
l'administration américaine s'est
exprimée sur l'implication du prince
héritier d'arabie saoudite mohammed bin
salman dans la triste disparition
dramatique du journaliste saoudien un
cachot guy est ce que monsieur mini cela
va faire évoluer la position de la
france sur ce dossier
plus largement qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de la politique américaine au
levant et au moyen-orient où de nouveaux
il nous semble que les difficultés tente
à s'accumuler
nous avons reçu il ya peu de temps le
représentant du kurdistan d'irak à paris
l'ambassadeur ali de la mari et il nous
disait quant à lui attendent beaucoup de
la nouvelle administration américaine
vous nous donnerez votre sentiment sur
cette évolution au moyen-orient en asie
les tensions se multiplient avec la
chine
qu'il s'agisse de l'oppression des de la
minorité ouïghoure d atteinte au
pluralisme politique
à hong kong des taons tension navale à
taïwan et en mer de chine méridionale où
notre marine rappelle régulièrement
l'attachement de la france au droit de
la mer et à la liberté de circulation et
au passage comme nous sommes aussi
commission de la défense nous saluons la
pâte et la patrouille au long cours du
sous marin nucléaire d'attaqué émeraude
qui a été dans cette partie du monde
pour rappeler ses libertés fondamentales
du droit de la mer alors que le
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken et le ministre de la défense
lloyd austin ont entamé une tournée
auprès des membres du quad qui réunit
l'australie l'inde et le japon pour
mieux faire face à la montée en
puissance militaire de la chine dans la
région qu'elle doit être selon vous le
positionnement de la france dans ce
contexte et dans cette partie du monde
sachant que nous disposons également de
partenariat stratégique avec l'inde et
l'australie
et que nous souhaitons bien évidemment
conserver notre présence dans cette
partie du monde je pense évidemment à la
nouvelle calédonie enfin nous
souhaiterions évoquer avec vous la
situation très préoccupante de la
birmanie ouzou où s'est déroulé un coup
d'état qui commence à devenir
particulièrement sanglant le bilan
humain ne cesse de se dégrader
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu a
condamné à l'unanimité le 10 mars
dernier la violence contre des
manifestants pacifiques
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la birmanie a
dénoncé je cite le bain de sang en cours
dans ce pays où 18 personnes de plus
sont mortes hier seulement dans les
manifestations et là aussi comment la
france peut oeuvrer à une désescalade et
à un retour du pouvoir aux institutions
civiles
sachant que de surcroît la france a
aussi quelques intérêts économiques dans
ce pays dont il faut obtenir compte
monsieur le ministre nous aurions
évidemment beaucoup d'autres sujets qui
mériteraient développer je pense qu'on
aura des questions complémentaires de la
part de nos collègues je vous rappelle
que votre intervention liminaire
liminaires et diffusée en direct sur le
site du sénat et que la seconde partie
de cette audition qui est consacré aux
questions réponses et qui vous permet de
parler avec la plus grande franchise
donnera lieu simplement à un compte
rendu écrit publié ultérieurement
vous connaissez notre méthode monsieur
mini vous avez la possibilité de vous
exprimer plus très viendront une série
de questions réponses monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
avec le plaisir de vous accueillir dans
notre commission
merci monsieur le président merci
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je suis désolé d'être dans
cette situation je suis en contact mais
je vais très bien je suis testé négatif
j'ai encore jusqu'à jeudi à à me
confiner mais vous faites partie d'une
forme d'aération d'une certaine manière
parce que c'est un plaisir de pouvoir
échanger avec vous comme comme à chaque
fois et donc j'essayerai de répondre à
vos questions et à vos préoccupations
je ne voulais pas repoussés parce que il
ya beaucoup d'actualité et la semaine
prochaine et une semaine très chargée
puisqu'il va y avoir à la fois la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne et la réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'otan à bruxelles plus un déplacement
doit faire à berlin
donc ça nous amener un peu plus tard et
donc je pense que c'était même si c'est
moins facile de dialoguer dans cette
configuration je pense que c'était quand
même utile qu'on puisse se parler
aujourd'hui je vais reprendre quelques
éléments que vous avez cité quelques
autres que je rajoute
et puis évidemment pourra parler de tout
dans la mesure de mes compétences pour
pour vous pour vous répondre
quelques mots quand même d'abord sur le
sahel puisque la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vus c'était dans un débat que vous
aviez initiés monsieur le président sur
la situation au sahel
c'était quelques jours avant le sommet
qui s'est tenu à à djamena et je dois
dire que les résultats de ce sommet ont
été ont été positifs dans la mesure où
les grands engagements de pau ont été
réactivées je rappelle qu'il y avait
quatre piliers au sommet de peau de la
lutte contre le terrorisme le
renforcement des capacités des forces
armées sahélienne le soutien au
redéploiement de de l'état des états
dans la foi d administration
territoriale des services de base et
enfin le l'ensemble de la stratégie de
développement et ce sommet je crois a
ouvert la voie à une amplification de la
dynamique qui avait été impulsée à pau
d'abord sur le plan opérationnel avec un
centre de décisions fortes qui vont
avoir repensé à l'impact sur le terrain
le maintien en particulier de l'effort
national français de bach cadres mais
aussi l'activation de takouba et le fait
que la force conjointe du sahel a
continué à se déployer avec des présence
accrue des désengagements des acteurs
qui pouvait être un petit peu contre âge
jusqu'à présent y compris la volonté
d'agir pour obtenir les financements de
la force conjointe
ce qui me paraît le plus important j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire depuis à
l'assemblée nationale c'est que le
sommet de djamena a marqué ce que
j'avais souhaité pour ma part lors du
débat que nous avons eu au sénat a
marqué la volonté d'un sursaut civile
d'un sursaut politique et d'un sursaut
de développement le sommet de posséder
le sort qu militaire qui a dernier
d'ailleurs des résultats assez
significatif
le sommet de djamena c'est le surf
civils politiques et de développement
ça s'est d'ailleurs manifesté quelques
jours avant le sommet de peau puisque le
sommet de n'djamena pardon puisque s'est
tenue à kidal
vous avez dû suivre ça le comité de
suivi de l'accord d'alger qui ne s'était
pas réunie ce comité de suivi depuis
longtemps
il s'était jamais réuni à kidal or c'est
tout à fait central de haut niveau de
symbolique pour marquer la paix la
réconciliation au mali et bien
évidemment nous sommes tout à fait
convaincu que c'est la mise en oeuvre
des dispositions de l'accord d'alger qui
permettra la stabilisation et qui permet
tease engagera aussi la plus grande
sérénité dans
le nord du mali en particulier cette
initiative a été importante puisque je
me suis j'ai participé à cette à ce
comité de suivi de de kidal en visio ou
des raisons de conformité sanitaire mais
c'était présidée par le ministre
algérien des affaires étrangères vous
m'aviez souvent interrogé sur la place
de l'algérie
la volonté algérienne d'aboutir à une
pacification au mali et dans le sahel
le fait que ce comité se soient réunis
sous sa présidence et à kidal était un
acte important auquel la france a
participé par mon par mon intermédiaire
il ya eu aussi la volonté de mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs pour un sursaut
civils en particulier pour ramener
l'autorité les services de l'état dans
les zones les plus vulnérables et de
faire en sorte
il ya une vraie mobilisation de
développement avec que parce que le
projet de loi sur le développement
solidaire dont on a déjà parlé beaucoup
avec vous y contribuera lorsqu'il sera
définitivement voté parce que ça
permettra d'engager encore davantage de
financements mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que il y a eu la
volonté de reprendre en main le projet
emblématique de la grande muraille verte
qui est un projet qui a été lancé
initialement par les africains qui
étaient un peu arrêté jusqu'à présent et
dans le cadre de la politique de
développement du sursaut développement
de ce soldat de la stabilisation ce
projet va reprendre forme et nous allons
le suivre avec beaucoup d'attention
il y à vraiment je pense une
mobilisation internationale en faveur du
sel
je l'avais indiqué lors de notre départ
au sénat elle est une réalité
à tel point que la coalition
internationale pour le sahel coalition
internationale que qu'il s'est mis en
oeuvre après le sommet de pau va se
réunir à berlin vendredi prochain en
formats un peu hybride mais ça montre
que si ça se tient à berlin c'est un
signe de la dimension européenne et
internationale de notre action commune
et 60 pays et organisations aujourd'hui
sont membres de cette coalition donc je
suis plutôt optimiste à la suite de la
vigueur de ce que l'on a senti à djamena
et la volonté commune de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait maintenant un vrai sursaut
civile est un vrai sursaut politique que
sur le sahel
je voudrais dire quelques mots au sirop
sur des questions liées au moyen-orient
d'abord parce que aujourd'hui face à ces
jours ci c'est le dixième anniversaire
de des manifestations de tayrac sur les
premières manifestations de la crise
syrienne je le dis avec beaucoup de
gravité puisque après une dizaine
décennie de chaos et d'atrocités
la situation reste extrêmement
incertaines néanmoins malgré la haute la
prise de pouvoir au gré cif systématique
de de reconquête territoriale par bachar
el assad il n'empêche que au bout de dix
ans est l'une des crises humanitaires
les plus graves que depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale il ya eu quatre cent
mille personnes qui ont perdu la vie
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des
syriens 13 millions de personnes sont
réfugiées ou déplacées et malgré tout
cela aujourd'hui deux zones échappent
encore à l'affluence de bachar el-assad
la province d'idlib nord-ouest qui comme
vous le savez est divisé entre le régime
et des groupes d'opposition en partie
terroristes en particulier le groupe
hyatt erawan
mais cette région du nord de l'est dont
on a beaucoup parlé il ya quelques mois
elle est toujours aujourd'hui sous
contrôle de groupes extérieurs au régime
de damas avec une partie de ces groupes
qui sont contrôlés par la crise c'est
quand même près de 4 millions
d'habitants tu donc ce n'est ce n'est
pas rien en terme de population on e
siècle par ailleurs une grande partie de
la population syrienne et le pays puis
par ailleurs comme vous savez il ya la
zone nord-est qui reste pour l'essentiel
sous le contrôle des forces
démocratiques syriennes dominé par les
turcs des cures pendant du pays y des
mets où il ya aussi un partage d'un flux
ans entre la turquie d'une part qu'on
conserve une zone tampon le long de sa
frontière
la halle régime d'autre part la russie
enfin qui effectuent des patrouilles sur
une partie de son territoire
et c'est aussi une zone extrêmement
sensible puisque le danger c'est de
reprendre pied dans les zones de
simplement arabe de ce secteur qui est
toujours à secteur de guerre est un
secteur en situation conflictuelle
soyons clairs après dix ans la victoire
du régime est une victoire en trompe
l'oeil dans toutes les zones placées
sous son contrôle règne l'instabilité la
criminalité la prédation des milices et
dans certains endroits la menace d'une
résurgence du terrorisme
force est de constater que le dispositif
qui est initié à genève dans le cac au
mythe et constitutionnel est ainsi un
dispositif feu en trompe l'oeil puisque
on voit bien que le régime de bachar
el-assad attend le processus électoral
qui sera un processus électoral
aujourd'hui biaisé puisque sommes pas au
rendez vous de ce que préconise la
résolution 22 54 du conseil de sécurité
qui suppose de vraies élections des
conditions permettant le retour sûr et
volontaire des réfugiés et la libération
des prisonniers détenus arbitrairement
ce sont les conditions d'un une vraie
transition politique en syrie
et aujourd'hui nous sommes loin du
compte et nous sommes très vigilants
pour notre part sur la nécessité
d'engager des actions pour que les
crimes les plus graves commis en syrie
ne dort pas appuyer nous participons
nous soutenions la commission d' enquête
internationale des deux commissions
pinheiro qui a été mise en place par le
conseil des droits de l'homme en 2011 et
le mécanisme international et impartial
et indépendant qui a été créé par la
résolution de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies donc nous n'avons pas fini
sur ce cette partie du but du proche
orient et nous continuons à la fois
aider humanitairement soutenir le
concert au conseil de sécurité
la mise en oeuvre de la résolution 22 54
et nous engager dans les actions contre
les crimes les plus graves commis en
syrie pour qu'ils ne restent pas ils ne
meurent pas un pub
toujours dans les situations de crise on
alors un peu rapidement dans la
description mais c'est le temps qui
risque de nous manquer je voudrais vous
dire quelques mots aussi sur la libye ce
sujet sur lequel nous sommes entretenu
ensemble depuis depuis longtemps et
savez que c'est une vidéo priorité parce
que les conséquences potentielles de
cette crise pour la france et pour
l'union européenne sur son majeur en
matière de sécurité comme en matière
migratoire mais des conséquences
majeures aussi pour la stabilité au
sahel en afrique du nord et en
méditerranée
et je dois vous dire que pour une fois
c'est très rare
soulignons le il y a des bonnes
nouvelles dans la mesure où il y a
désormais un gouvernement le
gouvernement d' abbey bas qui a été
validé par un vote de confiance de la
chambre des représentants
c'est un succès sans précédent
des initiatives qui a été prise par lee
nations unies dans le cadre du forum
politique qui s'est réuni à genève et
que nous avons nous-mêmes fortement
soutenu par des engagements d'entretiens
entre le président de la république et
différents acteurs par ma propre
contribution si je peux me permettre
en ayant avec le premier ministre des
pays bas avec le président du conseil
présidentiel même fille avait que le
président de la chambre des
représentants à qui la salle et beaucoup
d'entretien pour aboutir à ce qu'il y
ait cette légitimation de nouveaux lieux
de nouveaux responsables libyens nous
avons eu aussi à cet égard une action
très importante avec les allemands et
des italiens me suis rendu à rome la
semaine dernière
particulièrement sur ce sujet et il y à
un moment c'est trop fort de l'appeler
historique pour l'instant il ya un
moment positif en libye qui n'est pas
arrivé depuis longtemps
le nouveau représentant du
secrétaire général des nations unies
monsieur koubbi j'étais à paris la
semaine dernière nous sommes entretenu
sur la suite du processus qu'il faut
surveiller très minutieusement qui se
détraque c est orienté vers la
préparation des élections qui devraient
avoir lieu le 24 décembre prochain il
faut donc préparer c'est d'un
gouvernement de transition qui doit
préparer ces échéances et qui doit
parallèlement à cela mettre en oeuvre le
cessez le feu qui a eu lieu en octobre
dernier pour progressivement aboutir à
ce que en particulier la route entre
syrte et misrata puisse est ouverte mais
aussi que les participations extérieures
les milices extérieur reviennent
retourne dans les pays dont ils sont
originaires je pense en particulier à la
turquie et la russie et dans l'immédiat
il faut mettre en oeuvre des mesures de
confiance faire en sorte que la réforme
de la gouvernance économique puisse être
engagée et éviter les obstructions de
ceux qui voudraient le retour en arrière
la route est encore longue mais nous
venons de passer une étape très
significative
je tenais à vous à vous le dire parce
que serra et il ya là un espoir sur
lequel il faut être précautionneux mais
un espoir néanmoins manifestement
l'ensemble des acteurs libyens peut être
assez la de cette période de tension de
conflits qualité de de combat qui existe
dans ce pays donc je pense qu'il y a
maintenant une prise de conscience de la
nécessité de faire en sorte que cet au
delà du cessez-le-feu ce gouvernement
puisse être le gouvernement légitime qui
aboutira à un processus de paix est un
processus de fin de la guerre civile
avec le processus électoral qui
interviendra à la fin de l'année de 2021
pour rester dans les situations de crise
puisque vous m'avez amenée à en parler
monsieur le président je voudrais dire
aussi quelques mots sur la situation
dans le golfe et particulièrement sur
l'état d'avancement de la crise avec
l'iran
pensant que avec le retour des états
unis la volonté des états unis de
revenir dans l'accord de vienne il y a
une opportunité à saisir
même si aujourd'hui je dois vous le dire
la situation de tension grave qui existe
dans le golfe n'est pas sans rappeler la
situation de crise que nous avions connu
à l'été 2010 9
les activités nucléaires iraniennes se
développe en violation de l'accord
nucléaire devienne avec l'enrichissement
à 20% avec le renforcement de la
recherche développement avec la
suspension du protocole additionnel de
l'aï a et et parallèlement des attaques
déstabilisatrices sont observées à la
fois en irak
vous y avez fait référence monsieur le
président est en arabie séoudite et une
fois père hâtivement c'est indispensable
d'engager une désescalade détention et
que les premiers pas indispensables
doivent être qu'il y ait des rencontres
informelles pour permettre le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord de vienne est
parallèlement le renoncement par l'iran
à ces désengagements successifs qui ont
été effectués depuis depuis 2000 2018
s'est approché et partagé par nos
partenaires nous en nous y travaillons
beaucoup dans le cadre du e3 avec nos
amis allemands et britanniques et nous
avons vu avec les états unis et avec le
secrétaire d'état tony blinken
beaucoup de discussions en visio sur ce
sujet c'est à la suite
une rencontre que nous avons eue à
partir de paris avec tony blinken que
les états unis ont fait savoir
publiquement qu'ils avaient pour
objectif de retourner dans le gcp oies
et 7 sommes toujours dans cette
discussion nous envoyant des signaux aux
iraniens pour qu'on puisse avoir ce
retour qui prélude à une discussion
élargie au delà du gcp voix sur à la
fois les risques de déstabilisation
régionale mais aussi sur l'ensemble des
questions liées à la capacité missiles
hier de l'iran dont le retour gcp loi
c'est le point de départ pour une
discussion élargie avec l'iran ce n'est
pour l'instant que au niveau des
souhaits des attentions
il ya un problème tactique
il ya aussi une pas un problème interne
à l'iran dans une situation particulière
puisque nous sommes assez proches des
élections présidentielles qui auront
lieu au mois deux au mois de juin donc
folon t affirmé volonté affichée mais
attention maintenu des escalades
indispensable urgence d'avancé c'est ce
à quoi nous consacrons aujourd'hui dans
le format de trois que nous souhaitons
bientôt voir élargi dans une discussion
plus large
vous avez évoqué aussi le président le
plus largement le fait que nous sommes
dans une nouvelle zone transatlantique
et j'utilise le passage iranien pour
évoquer cette nouvelle donne nous sommes
déterminés à avancer avec la nouvelle
administration américaine et depuis
l'entrée en fonction du président by
donne il y a un état d'esprit différent
au pouvoir aller de l'avant ensemble en
bâtissant une nouvelle relation
transatlantique entre une europe qui
assume sa puissance et des états unis
qui assument leurs responsabilités les
défis ne manquent pas et
nous avons eu avec mon homologue
américain dean cain plusieurs entretiens
depuis son arrivée le dernier en date
ayant eu lieu dimanche dernier
nous nous avançons sur toute une série
de sujets j'observe néanmoins pour faire
référence à vos propos introductif que
les premières initiatives prises par les
déplacements du secrétaire d'état
américain vont vers l'asie puisque ce
déplacement au japon et en corée et à
déplacement significatif et que par
ailleurs tony blinken doit rencontrer
nos collègues son collègue notre
collègue huang yi notre collègue chinois
dans quelques jours avant qu'il ne
vienne à en europe pour la réunion des
musées affaires étrangères de l'otan qui
se tiendra la semaine prochaine ce sera
sa première visite est sa première
rencontre en présentiel
depuis l'arrivée de la nouvelle
administration américaine
mais dans le cas de cette nouvelle donne
en atlantique j'observe aussi que nous
avons pu parler de manière approfondie
avec john kerry que j'ai reçu la semaine
dernière à paris sur le défi climatique
et et la préparation de la coop 26 de
glasgow qui va être une
une réunion déterminante qui sera
décisif pour le respect de l'accord de
paris car elle doit permettre d'aboutir
à l'annonce de nouvelles contributions
déterminées au niveau national les
fameux cds est notamment de la part de
grands émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre
que sont la chine l'inde et les états
unis je vais y revenir mais cette
rencontre de glasgow doit aussi
préserver la dynamique en matière de
finance climat au delà de 2025 de la
part des pays développés et enfin 7
comme 26 doit finaliser les règles de
mise en oeuvre de l'accord de paris liés
au marché carbone dont nous avons un
grand chantier devant dos les états unis
vont organiser un sommet sur le climat
le 22 avril prochain un sommet
préparatoire à la coop vensys
logiquement ils doivent non seulement
confirmé leur retour dans les accords de
paris puisqu'il est déjà fait mais aussi
annoncer les initiatives financières et
les initiatives de niveau d'ambition il
compte proposer à la cop16 de blagues
aux le plus beau donc c'est une nouvelle
relation transatlantique pendant l'état
d'esprit dans les actes je reviendrai
peut-être dans un instant dans les
questions sur le proche-orient et il
apporte que nous puissions décliner
cette nouvelle donne dans tous les
domaines y compris en renforçant notre
souveraineté européenne
cette nouvelle donne on la constate
aussi dans le domaine commercial
puisqu'il ya eu la suspension des droits
de douane dans le conflit et airbus
boeing qui est effective depuis jeudi
dernier
c'est une grève pour l'instant et devant
tout faire pour que dans le délai
imparti des quatre mois nous puissions
aboutir à dépasser cette situation
profite ul qui ne fait que favoriser en
fait l'aviation l'industrie aéronautique
chinoise et nous vous devons aussi
profité de cette trêve pour remettre sur
la table les autres différends qui pèse
inutilement sur les relations
commerciales transatlantique que ce soit
sur le différend concernant l'acier et
l'aluminium différents déjà un petit peu
anciens je sois sur la fiscalité du
numérique et l'état d'esprit est plutôt
positif même si pour l'instant il n'est
pas encore un peu tôt pour constater
qu'il y ait des avancées déterminantes
dans ce domaine mais il faut constater
que l'europe qui aujourd'hui discute
avec les états unis sur la refondation
du lien transatlantique n'est pas la
même europe que celle qui existait il ya
quatre ans l'europe et est devenu plus
déterminés plus déterminés affirmer sa
souveraineté affirmer sa puissance à
être un partenaire des états unis mais
un partenaire qui a sa propre à six et
nous avons dit à plusieurs reprises à
anthony blinken qu'il était préférable
pour les états unis d'avoir un allié
fort canal y est dépendant et
j'ai été frappé je vous le dis pour
répondre à votre préoccupation monsieur
le président lors de l'entretien que
quand tony blinken a eu avec les
affaires étrangères des vingt-sept
il y a quelques jours à bruxelles
c'était un entretien vision mes
entretiens il a insisté particulièrement
sur la nécessité d'avoir une union
européenne unie et partenaires y compris
dans le domaine stratégique ce qui est
quand même une
un discours que nous n'avions pas
entendu depuis longtemps peut-être même
jamais entendu au moins avec que cette
force et cette détermination
je voudrais aussi vous dire deux mots
sur la birmanie puisque vous n'y avez
invité pour constater avec vous que le
récent coup d'état a marqué un arrêt
brutal du processus de démocratisation
que la france et l'union européenne
soutenait depuis une décennie que la
dégradation de la situation en birmanie
s'accélère
l'armée birmane se rend coupable de
crimes contre la population du pays des
violations des droits de l'homme se sont
encore accentuées les jours derniers
jusqu'à et jusqu'à hier nombreuses
arrestations et est de plus en plus de
morts résultant d'une répression brutale
et donc face à cette situation
inacceptable nous avons réagi au niveau
de l'union européenne avec beaucoup de
fermeté d'unités c'était indispensable
d'abord la condamnation du coup d'état
là vous faites solidairement de teck
qu'il s'est produit mais aussi nous
avons adopté des sanctions fortes à
l'encontre des responsables du coup
d'état
et c'est ces sanctions vont être mises
en oeuvre très rapidement puisque les
discussions techniques sont en train de
se terminer à boxait nous allons valider
la mise en oeuvre de ces sanctions dès
le conseil des affaires étrangères de
lundi prochain
avec évidemment la suspension de tout
soutien budgétaire avec aussi des
mesures au très puissant très
directement les responsables
du coup d'état militaire non seulement
les personnes mais aussi leur propre aux
intérêts économiques et nous faisons
aussi en sorte que au niveau du conseil
de sécurité des prises de position 8,7
prises ainsi que au niveau du conseil
des droits de l'homme
cela a été fait il ya une réunion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
le 26 février où une opposition très
forte et nous sommes en relation avec
les membres de l'asian je m'entretiens
régulièrement avec mes homologues
singapouriens indonésien malaisien pour
qu'il y ait une action forte par les uns
et par les autres pour faire pression il
faut une pression internationale il faut
une protestation internationale
en plus des actions de sanctions que je
viens de d'évoquer il y a un instant
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
commençant pour ne pas y plonger déjà et
beaucoup de temps pour exposer certains
perdent 1 point
je peux maintenant répondre à vos
questions
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
sur les différents sujets qui vous
préoccupent en priorité il ya beaucoup
de points tu n'es pas évoqué que je
comptais évoqué au départ dans mon
propos liminaire mai pour éviter qu'il
soit trop long je préfère que cela fasse
l'objet de questions que je puisse
répondre très très clairement sur vos
interrogations
[Musique]